in dieser woche war deutsche ärztetag in
münster und zum thema ärzte gibt es
aktuell eine gute und eine schlechte
nachricht die gute in deutschland haben
wir eine überdurchschnittliche
ärztedichte die schlechte diese ärzte
die wir haben sind leider wahnsinnig
schlecht verteilt nach wie vor wollen
viel zu wenige aufs land in manchen
regionen lebt eine regelrechte null bock
generation wirklich mindestens 2600 land
art stellen sind aktuell unbesetzt bis
2030 könnten es wohl 11.000 seite blöde
sache blöde sache ist das eigentlich ein
neues problem landarzt und das bedeutet
heute fast jede nacht aufstehen und
viele kilometer fahren denn auf dem land
sterben ärzte aus vor allem im winter
macht der doktor seine krankenbesuche
lieber zu pferde als zu wagen ali ist
weniger reparaturanfällig als das auto
ja damals war der ali in vielen
bereichen die weniger reparaturanfällig
alternative landarztmangels schon in den
sechzigern eins der wenigen probleme die
älter sind als ich denken sie da mal
drüber nach dabei verdient man auf dem
land nicht weniger als arzt es geht um
infrastruktur zu wenig schulen
kindergärten kann die arztgattin einen
teeladen aufmachen damit sie nicht fremd
geht solche sachen
aber natürlich hat das landleben auch
vorteile für ärzte ich habe ja noch nie
seitdem ich hier praktizieren eier
gekauft ja ich brauche immer von meinen
patienten wohl nicht auch um eine
passieren denn wusste von meiner
patienten frische gemüse um beim
passieren dann geschälte spargel von mal
passieren denn blutwurst rinderhälften
marihuana alles von meinem patienten
er muss nur aufpassen dass er sich nicht
den magen verdirbt sonst muss er zum
arzt und da ist keiner
nur 6 prozent der deutschen hausärzte
sind gerade unter 40 mehr als zwei
drittel älter als 50 in manchen praxen
kein witz arbeiten über 80-jährige weil
sie einfach keinen nachfolger finden für
ihren laden das so traurig das ist so
traurig mein damals ja ein krasser fall
von senioren ausbeutung hier neue ard
serie in aller freundschaft die sehr
sehr alten ärzte
ein notfall innere brutto wir müssen
sofort operieren was operieren oder doch
ein fakt jetzt zählt jede sekunde
in aller freundschaft die sehen sie
alles im kasten
so jetzt zielgerichtet versehen
ja
es ist ja auch alles kein wunder als
niedergelassener landarzt hast du das
volle unternehmerrisiko endlose
autofahrten 14 stunden tage plus den
ganzen bürokratie albtraum nach
feierabend
ja natürlich arbeiten da viele lieber
angestellt im krankenhaus kurz gesagt
landarzt ist ein schöner beruf ein
wichtiger beruf aber du brauchst dafür
tatsächlich landeier aus stahl
das ist so was tun gegen den krassen
mangel in manchen dörfern kriegen neue
ärzte schon häuser geschenkt von der
gemeinde oder die hand der tochter des
bürgermeisters hier so wird man da
begrüßt ein augenlider je ein
überschwängliches stehen für den neuen
augenarzt in finsterwalde ja so kann
leider nicht jeder begrüßt werden der
auf dem land eine praxis eröffnet der
augenarzt von finsterwalde
es klingt wie ein ganz schlechter heimat
für immer im blick der augenarzt von
finsterwalde so nordrhein-westfalen
macht's mal richtig in nrw geht ein teil
der studienplätze nur an zukünftige
landärzte dann muss der abischnitt nicht
mehr ganz so dolle sein
dafür verpflichten die jungen menschen
sich für zehn jahre dorf mehr neue
ärztezentren in öffentlicher hand werden
auch schön meine schließlich leisten wir
uns eines der teuersten
gesundheitssysteme der welt 330
milliarden kostet das die bürger jedes
jahr
und wenn gar nichts mehr geht in der
aller tiefsten pampa hilft neuerdings na
wer die deutsche bahn
sie haben richtig gehört plötzlich für
was gut die deutsche bahn testet nämlich
den sogenannten medi bus eine voll
ausgestattete arztpraxis auf rädern der
medi bus fährt gerade durch die
hessische provinz und behandelt sagen
wir freiwillige
landarztmangel das ist ein uraltes
deutsches problem dass wir scheinbar nur
sehr sehr langsam in den griff kriegen
für uns vor ort genau da wo hase und
igel keinen arzt mehr finden
tina hausten ach ja das landleben
eigentlich ein traum
billige immobilien und jede menge
parkplätze und viel kontakt zu helfen
nur eines darf man hier auf gar keinen
fall krank werden wegen ärztemangel
deshalb ist es gerade hier so wichtig
sich gesund zu ernähren fit zu bleiben
viel an der frischen luft zu sein denn
das erspart den arztbesuch aber hier
kommt die lösung der medicus wenn der
patient nicht zum arzt kommt der abfahrt
mit dem bus
und das ist erst der anfang
alle dienstleistungen die auf dem
landweg gespart wurden kommen jetzt mit
dem bus die folge ist die geburtsklinik
die mobile polizeiwache denn warum
braucht es jede gemeinde ein polizist
[Musik]
hier ist die mobile darf schule und
direkt nebenan das mobile
bestattungsunternehmen und auf dem land
ohne internet besonders wichtig der
rollende puff ja dabei zahlen die lampen
oder doch auch steuern was für eine
unverschämtheit ganze region so
aufzugeben
andererseits wo ist kein bus mit den
leuten die das interessiert ja hier
tja leider leider kann der tolle medi
bus aber nicht überall sein
doch auch dafür gibt es jetzt eine
lösung online sprechstunden wo man den
arzt nur noch per skype trifft so forsch
röder damit er das auch durch dürfen sie
maximal tja das wählen offendorf können
sie sterben landleben dann lieber tot
überm zaun hin
hans de schreibt über die heute show ihr
seid die richtigen links [ __ ]
besonders welke die stradivari unter den
arschgeigen bei euch smileys
freudentränen freudentränen freundin
trennen freund rennkurs mit herz vielen
dank für ihr freundliches feedback für
ein exklusives geigensolo von oliver
welke
abonnieren sie den kanal